hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ooto
TV the content shown in this video has
been submitted by various players to
ooto TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful
[Music]
owner
that
sh
come
yeah
[Music]
oh
C
come
[Music]
on
yeah
[Music]
k
h
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description want to be featured in ooto
TV send in your Clips by following these
steps before you submit your Clips make
sure the quality of the video is clear
put your IGN as a file name for your
video limit submissions to three to five
Clips a week per category don't spam
submissions and don't send folders with
your Clips on avoid full length matches
or just cut the clip you want on the
desired play Until the End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every oo TV series
Once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your
[Music]
IGM also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay
[Music]
match please understand that it may take
some time for some clips to be featured
because of the review
process
[Music]